in den zentren der meisten galaxien
befinden sich supermassereiche schwarze
löcher
doch die sensation ihn viel viel mehr
galaxien als gedacht befinden sich sogar
zwei supermassereiche schwarze löcher
und ein forschungsteam hat jetzt den
todes tanz nämlich dass spätstadium der
todesspirale kurz vor der verschmelzung
dieser schwarzen löcher beobachtet die
spektakulären aufnahmen dazu und alle
wichtigen facts jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction gibt's täglich spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen knapp 500 galaxien hat das
forschungsteam systematisch untersucht
alle im umkreis von 330 millionen
lichtjahren dabei waren die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
auf der spur der supermassereichen
schwarzen löcher ins zentrum der
galaxien kurz vor der verschmelzung bei
ihrer untersuchung nutzen sie das swift
röntgenteleskop um aktive galaxienkerne
zu detektieren wenn dies gelang nutzen
sie die datenbanken vom keck teleskop
auf hawaii und dem
hubble-weltraumteleskop um sich die
aufnahmen genauer anzusehen seit einiger
zeit ist bekannt dass viele galaxien
nicht nur eines sondern direkt 2
supermassereiche schwarze löcher in
ihrem zentrum aufweisen nach der analyse
des forschungsteams war dies bei 17
prozent der aktiven galaxien der fall an
pärchen bestehend aus zwei schwarzen
löchern umkreist sie sich gegenseitig
viel viel mehr als eigentlich gedacht
denn diese letzte phase der annäherung
sei eigentlich extrem kurz und so wohl
nur bei einem prozent der aktiven
galaxien zu beobachten so zumindest die
bisherige annahme aber es ist ganz
anders und eine aktuelle simulation
zeigt tatsächlich dass schwarze löcher
fünf mal länger in der entfernung von 10
bis 30 tausend lichtjahren verweilen als
wenn sie nur noch weniger als 10.000
lichtjahre voneinander entfernt sehen
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
michael kost aus zürich es war ziemlich
beeindruckend diese verschmelzenden
galaxienkerne mit ihrem gigantischen
schwarzen löchern so nah beieinander zu
sehen besonders spektakuläre bilder
zeigen sogar dass spätstadium der
schwarzen löcher eben kurz vor ihrer
verschmelzung eine art todes tanz wie es
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler bildlich beschreiben sie
konnten zudem beobachten dass die
gigantischen schwarzen löchern noch
mal rasant anwachsen kurz bevor sie
kollidieren und eben auch dieses extreme
wachstum in der endphase überraschte die
experten und expertinnen dazu laura
blecher von der university of florida
dieses rasante wachstum der schwarzen
löcher vor der verschmelzung verrät uns
wie wichtig galaxien verschmelzungen für
die enorme größe solcher schwerkraft
giganten sind der bisher längsten
theorie zufolge findet vor einer solchen
karambolage tatsächlich eine art
todesspirale statt beide zentralen
schwarzen löcher umkreisen sich ihr
abstand zueinander wird dabei immer
kleiner und schließlich kollidieren sie
dabei werden gravitationswellen frei
diese hatte albert einstein schon im
jahr 1916 vorhergesagt obwohl er
schwarze löcher eigentlich damals für
unmöglich doch bis gravitationswellen
zum ersten mal nachgewiesen werden
konnte dauerte es ganze 100 jahre 2017
war es endlich soweit der nobelpreis für
sieg ging an drei gravitationswellen
forscher aus den usa
denn sie hatten jeweils mit ihren
experimenten und mit ihrer
grundlagenforschung zum ersten mal den
nachweis der gravitationswellen
erbringen können diese werden vor allem
von grossen objekten im alle erzeugt wie
eben von schwarzen löchern und
neutronensternen wenn solche massen
schnell genug beschleunigt werden wird
die raumzeit so sehr gekrümmt dass die
gravitationswellen auch noch in größerer
entfernung aufzuspüren sind wenn sich
die wellen im weltall ausbreiten wird
alles was sie passiert melden förmlich
gedehnt und zusammengedrückt doch selbst
wenn die gravitationswellen sehr stark
sind verformen sie das weltall nur
minimal der todes tanz der schwarzen
löcher bei denen solche
gravitationswellen entstehen ist
jedenfalls wirklich spektakulär konnte
bisher aber nur in einigen wenigen
fällen beobachtet werden der grund
solche supermassereichen schwarzen
löcher verstecken sich quasi hinter
wolken aus staub und gas so ist es auch
heute noch fast unmöglich paare dieser
giganten aufzuspüren und auf frischer
tat zu ertappen sogar mit sehr
leistungsstarken teleskopen ist es
derzeit noch unmöglich selbst nahe
gelegenen galaxien gut aufzulösen große
hoffnung liegt deswegen auf der neuen
generationen der teleskope
beispielsweise auf dem european
triemli large telescope e elt über das
wir hier bei pixum science fiction ja
schon einmal berichtet hatten denn das
führt uns in eine neue ära der
astronomie und das in gewaltigen
dimensionen das projekt läuft seit 2012
endet 2014 wurde sein bau genehmigt zehn
jahre später also 2024 wird das mega
teleskop auf einem abgelegenen
berggipfel in chiles atacama-wüste dann
wohl erstmalig an den start gehen und
dann könnte es vielleicht tatsächlich
galaxienkerne die sich umkreisen
sichtbar machen übrigens hat solch ein
schicksal an kollisionen wohl auch
unsere galaxie die milchstraße schon
mehrmals durchlebt denn auch sie ist
bereits öfter mit anderen galaxien
kollidiert beispielsweise besonders
heftig von mehr als zehn milliarden
jahren offenbar bislang was bei solch
einer karambolage mit den schwarzen
löchern im zentrum der jeweiligen
galaxie passiert bei der milchstraße
gibt es die vermutung dass in ihrem halo
also der kugelförmige schale um die
galaxie noch überbleibsel eine
supermassereichen schwarzen loch zu
finden sind und dass das eben bei
früheren kollisionen mit zwerggalaxien
entstanden ist schwarze löcher erklärt
draufklicken anschauen und bei zwings
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran